oh
[Music]
baby dude hi I'm Julio Rodriguez and I'm
Jordan Heideman today was your day off
and we decided to go to a soccer field
Have Some Fun With a Little Help From My
Wells Fargo activecast Visa card
[Music]
hey what's up my man hey how you doing
we called earlier we're at the field got
you the feel right over there ready for
you I've never heard
a code for
one or more Rookie of the Year it feels
really good to bring that back to the
Dominican Republic it felt very
rewarding in a way ow is that your toe a
little bit yeah
I could hear that one I have a rookie in
this playing pro soccer is a really hard
profession senior out there is
definitely really cool
be careful yeah I feel like pointing
your foot more angled a little bit
because I feel like you're getting too
much help actually
I think he has like the determination to
kind of learn new things and like he
practiced and trained he could do it
just with his mindset plant beside the
ball point where you wanted to go
I feel like we try to play together
we're not really competitive with each
other but we like to compete against
somebody else that was good it was a
little bit better that was good now you
got the hang of it and you know how to
shoot you know how to lift off the
ground so at each point we're gonna move
back and you gotta hit nothing but the
net on each shot no bounce no any of
that is gonna hit B in the goal nothing
but net
we're gonna start on the six
nice PK spot this is gonna be a tough
one it's definitely getting for the back
yes nothing but nuts oh let's go last
one yeah you hit it yeah I'll buy your
ice cream yeah as many flavors as you
want okay perfect you say it you get the
scoop if you miss though you buy us ice
cream it's a little far though it is far
but it's a challenge what's the point I
fly over in a good spot
I see oh too much pressure I added
[Music]
oh god oh so close
I got you I'm so excited for ice cream
and I'm just like thinking of yeah
you're gonna treat me I'm just trying to
think of like how many scoops out put
her on the card
[Music]
fudge brownie ice cream can I please get
cookies and cream milkshake
it's a shake for you thank you what's
the total it's gonna be 14 dollars
going training playing some soccer then
we get some ice cream I almost glad I
was not bad I like the ice cream you
would have gone any other way yeah I'd
probably like getting it for you oh
that's so sassy that's so cute that was
so much fun hanging out in Tampa with
Jordan and I love that I earned
unlimited two percent cash Wars all my
purchases with the Wells Fargo active
guys credit card see you guys soon
[Music]